let's get this over with Bell's magical
world I can safely say that this is the
first Disney sequel I've seen during
this Disney cember that is clearly just
doing the bare minimum help
I would even know if it's doing that I
guess with the popularity of Beauty and
the Beast enchanted Christmas they felt
well why not do another one just
something anything
I don't know throw it out there and
that's what this movie feels like they
just took something anything and vomited
it up before us what's the story there
isn't one well no there's like four or
five it's not even really a movie it
doesn't really begin it doesn't really
end it starts off in a lame-ass CG
library it gives us the set up again how
Belle traveled to a castle and comes
across all these little characters and
the beasts and then it's just a few
stories about when she was there there's
a part where she's angry at the beasts
and they fight over who's gonna
apologize first that ends then there's a
part about Lumiere being in love with
the feather duster that ends there's one
where mrs. Potts feels left out that
ends and there's one with a bird with a
broken wing that ends and then it all
ends that was it it doesn't even wrap up
the opening at least had a narrator
saying hey this is going on the ending
just it just stops
it's pointless it's stupid there is no
reason for it to exist it is that a
movie is that what counts as a movie
talk about false advertising look at the
cover
it shows Belle in the yellow dress the
famous yellow dress it doesn't even
appear in this what does appear really
sucks
well the animation in enchanted
Christmas wasn't phenomenal it's still
pretty good again you could tell they
were trying they just didn't have the
budget to do as well as the first one
but they were really trying to make it
look like the first one well looks like
they took the budget and chanted
Christmas and cut that in half again
look at everybody they look awful
this doesn't look like a beauty in the
Beast movie it looks like Beauty and the
Beast the TV show like what they do with
a lad and the TV show was that the idea
was this going to be a beauty in the
Beast TV show but then they just
scrapped at the last minute but the
figure here we have four or five these
already done just slap a movie title on
it and say Belle's magical world what's
even magical about it we seen all this
before there's nothing new it's just a
more used to this there's nothing even
that magical about it what is that weird
face says
become a meme magical okay actually it
is a little magical but everything else
is totally pointless if you're just
gonna lazily throw these things together
and expect it to be a movie expect it to
be judged as a movie this is clearly
just something for three or four
year-olds I know what you're thinking oh
is that like with the original Beauty
and the Beast was no it was nominated
for Best Film not this anime film that
didn't even exist yet maybe it's because
of this movie that that category exists
I just come on it's Disney is there
anything good in it
well I like this line what shall we do
there's only one thing to do we must
scream like bloodless cowards oh this
one's kind of cute hold on Lumiere
listen rate the option I don't do
intention of doing otherwise
I guess the cartoony animation isn't
that bad but the animation went supposed
to look serious like an belle of a beast
is just pathetic so yeah two lines from
Lumiere some cartoony stuff that because
of the low bar I have to congratulate
them on looking cartoony but aside from
that no there's really nothing if you
have a toddler that likes anything show
this because they'll like anything
Belle's magical world it sucks and on to
the next one bye
[Music]
you